foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar ultraplex Multiplex technology
tagging technology for Mouse and human
multiplexing
I am Kaylee Bach of labyrinths and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Leica biosystems
to learn more please visit
leicabiosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
with that I'd like to now welcome our
speaker Dr Helen Snyder director
multiplexing product management at cell
idx a Leica biosystems company Helen you
may now begin your presentation
things with Haley for that introduction
well I am delighted to be here I really
appreciate the opportunity to talk to
you about ultraplex
which is our Italian technology for
generating both Mouse and human
Multiplex panels with both fluorescent
and chromogenic feed heads
so what is the ultraplex technology well
it is a platform technology which on its
first iteration we've applied to
Multiplex IHC
however it has the potential to be
applied to many different readouts our
primary goal was to develop a technology
which was extremely simple rapid and
easy to adopt
something you could run on equipment you
can really have in your laboratory
and as I said we also wanted it to be
rapid so that you could stay in the
morning scan after lunch and then
analyze your data the same day
so how does it work
the basis of the technology involves
labeling individual primary antibodies
with multiple copies of a specific
peptide light tag
each primary antibody is stable with a
different tag which is what allows us to
add all the antibodies simultaneously as
a cocktail
so using fluorescent Multiplex IHC as an
example and I apologize I don't have a
pointer on this presentation so if you
could look at the far left image or just
start from there
so the tissue undergoes a single episode
retrieval step followed by the
application of a cocktail of primary
antibodies each label with a different
peptide-like tag
the tissue is incubated washed then a
cocktail of anti-text secondaries each
labeled with a different fluorescent tag
is applied to the tissue
this means that you get amplification
from the multiple copies of a specific
tag on the primary antibody and also
from multiple copies of a fluorophore on
the specific anti-tag secondary
so sometimes people attempt to set up
Multiplex IHC using primary antibodies
of different species so this is rather
Limited in that you need good antibodies
of different species might try to use
one Mouse antibody and one rabbit
antibody and then detect with for
example anti-mouse and anti-rabid
secondaries
now but sometimes this is impossible to
to do as it um
good antibodies aren't always available
of the specificity you want in a
different species and then what if you
want to use all rabbit monoclonals which
um actually even all the same isotype
so what the ultraplex tagging does in
effect is it makes each antibody its own
species as each primer is recognized by
the tag that we add
um and then the anti-tech secondary so
this gives us huge flexibility it
doesn't matter to us what species the
antibody is we can use all of the same
species in the same ultraplex cocktail
so as I said our primary goal was to
develop something that was simple and
rapid and this is very simple and Rapid
in fact it uses simple standard primary
antibodies secondary antibody workflow
except instead of using one antibody at
a time it uses cocktails for antibodies
so our second goal was to develop a
multiplex IHC technology with both
fluorescent and chromogenic readouts
which would take you all the way from
your pre-clinical
biomarker studies in Mouse all the way
through to your human translational
studies using our research use only
reagents
and of course ultimately to clinical but
obviously we're not quite there yet
so if you look over to the left these
are our human translational Solutions
the first two panels are fluorescent and
the lower two panels chromogenic
over there on the right the upper two
para Mouse pre-clinical tissue biomarker
Solutions and below that we have really
our solutions for
multiplexing of custom biomarkers
so for a little more detail if you go
back up to the top left these are our
human ultraplex fluorescent panels which
are ready to use so this is hi1 through
six they are predefined four Plex panels
which if you're working in the area of
Immunology will make a lot of sense they
include
different lineage markers for immune
cells as well as checkpoint markers and
tumor markers
below this we have ultraplex human
fluorescent modular panels on demand so
modular is a
an approach which allows you to look at
a menu of qualified biomarkers and
choose the four that you want to
incorporate into your panel
you choose the four or four sets and you
place the order
below that are our promogenic Human
Solutions
ultraplex human chromogenic
panels ready to use our cpo1 through
cpo3 and I'll show those to you in a
minute
below that are our chromogenic panels
and requests so basically if we have
qualified
antibodies by fluorescence Multiplex IHC
then we have a really good chance of
being able to apply those to chromogenic
Multiplex by HC so if you see biomarkers
that you like just ask us about
chromogenic panels
then over there to the right the mouse
Ultra Planet ultraplex fluorescent
modular panels with mass we went
straight to modular because people
always have different panels that they
like to use
so again it's the same approach you take
a look at the menu of qualified
biomarkers choose the four you want the
fluorophore sets and then place the
order
again if we've qualified antibodies by
fluorescence then there's a good chance
that they will work in chromogenic
multiplexing so you can place a request
for a mouse chromogenic Multiplex panel
below that we have Ultra tag and path
idx so Ultra Turk are
do it yourself Multiplex labeling kits
so you are able to label your own
antibodies each tag labels one antibody
so if you want to create a four-plex
fluorescent panel you would choose four
four kits and we also have kits to
create chromogenic Multiplex panels too
and if you would rather we develop your
custom panel we can do that through path
idx
so ultraplex fluorescent and
probioogenic Multiplex IHC how does that
work
so again if you look at the top of the
flow diagram we have Ultra tag labeling
so this is what we do at cell idx in
manufacturing but it could also be what
you do with the ultra tear kits labeling
your own antibodies this is followed by
a single and chain retrieval step and
then you apply the cocktail of primary
primary antibodies simultaneously on the
tissue section whether you then proceed
to fluorescent Multiplex ahc or
chromogenic Multiplex yhc
so looking over to the left to begin
with with the fluorescent multiplexing
after you've added the primary
antibodies you incubate wash and then
you come back with a cocktail of
anti-tag secondaries each labeled with a
different floor
and the runtime for this is very rapid
on your bond directs it will be about
three and a half hours
the image that I'm showing below that is
a staining of breast cancer
so the ring membrane staining in red is
the her2 molecule
the blue nuclear staining is the Estuary
receptor and the green nuclear staining
is progesterone receptor where those are
two two are co-expressed in the nucleus
it appears as that kind of turquoise
color
and then the pink nuclear staining is Ki
67 so with this one panel on one tissue
section you can actually subdivide
breast cancer into the four main
subtypes
if we now look at chromogenic Multiplex
staining on the right you can see again
you add the same cocktail of three
primary antibodies although the
concentrations are a little different
for chromogenic
you then add one anti-tag label with ap
and a second anti-tag label with hrp you
develop with the AP and then the hrp
chromogens
then the first anti-tag hrp undergoes an
hrp arrest step so this is to kill the
hrp so it does not interfere with the
subsequent staining step which is to add
a second anti-tug label with hrp and
then develop with the second hrp
chromogen
so the image that I'm showing you there
and I'm sorry it's quite it's quite
small but you can and we've made a
little more complex because instead of
read her two staining it's now blue on
the chromogenic staining but you can
clearly see the blue membrane staining
for her2
the red nuclear staining for the
estrogen receptor and where there's a
co-expression of the estrogen and
progesterone receptors the nuclei appear
Orange
so again as I mentioned it's a simple
rapid standard uses a simple rapid
standard primary antibody secondary
antibody IHC workflow using cocktails of
antibodies
we have both human and mouse biomatic
panels
and the technology is primary antibody
species independent
so why is that important
well for us it's important in that
it gives us really ultimate flexibility
in the antibodies that we use in fact
frequently a lot of our antibodies will
be rabbit monoclonals they're very high
Affinity antibodies so we can easily
make four panels using rabbit
monoclonals or or Mouse monoclonals it
doesn't matter to us
and so why would it matter to our
customers well if you're also planning
on making your own Multiplex panel using
Ultra Tech then it's nice to be able to
use multiple antibodies from the same
species but also you might have a
favorite antibody that you've used for a
lot of different uh studies and you want
to include it in your panel and maybe
there are same species also within that
panel then again it doesn't matter for
you depending on what the primary
antibody is you can use it regardless of
the species
another Advantage is that it's uh has a
single and chain retrieval step for IHC
again why is this important well Sun
multiplexing Technologies use iterative
rounds of Antion retrievals so it's
stripping and staining stripping and
staining stripping and staining and this
can affect the levels of antigen
expression at different stages and
sometimes the tissue morphology
and so we don't have this problem at all
with ultraplex in that
we don't have to care about the uh the
order in which the antibodies are added
because they're all simultaneous and
also we don't have to worry about the
expression or the morphology because
there's only the single engine retrieval
step
um also because
increasingly the tissue biopsies that
we're looking at are increasingly small
often we'll be looking at
how you might be looking at in treatment
biopsies and frequently these are small
needle core biopsies and so we've had
customers who are working on needle
called biopsies who are a little
concerned in case
um
with a small tissue sample that if
there's a very prolonged procedure that
they actually might lose the tissue from
the sample but because we only do a
single entry retrieval step that's
definitely an advantage of ultraplex
so the fluorescent Multiplex IHC panels
are we have four to five Flex panels
routinely we do four Flex panels but we
can do five
of the chromogenic we can do three or
four Plex panels
so what I'm showing on the flow diagram
is obviously a three Plex panel but if
we wanted to uh create that as a four
Plex panel or we would do is we we would
add all the primaries simultaneously all
four of them at the beginning and then
after what I've shown you here we would
do another hrprs step and come back with
a third anti-tag hrp and a third hrp
parameter
ultraplex chromogenic Multiplex IHC and
Leica instrumentation why is this
special well ultraplex is a chromogenic
multiplex staining technology which is
simple fast and fully automated it
generates beautiful images and data on
biomark expression and spatial
localization of key cell subtypes using
the bond RX staining system and the
perio gt450 scanner
so the image that I'm showing the flow
diagram over there to the left is the
one I've shown you before but I did just
want to emphasize here the reagents that
you would need for the staining so
obviously you would use your usual Bond
wash Solutions and your bond directs
epitope retrieval solution and all of
the images that I've shown you so far
have been with the er2 appetite
retrieval solution
you'd also need to order the bond
polymer refined red detection kit and
the bond blue chromogen but included in
within the ultraplex kit are the
antibody cocktails and the antibody
diluent
the hrp arrest solution the yellow
chromogen
and purple hematoxylin and blue
hematoxylin counter stains so that you
have the option of one or the other
you have the bond RX 7.0 software bxd 25
or above the cell ID extrimagenic
protocol which is so idx rby is
pre-loaded onto the software so you just
need to load your reagents and hit the
Run button the image over there
a chance showing was produced on the
Imperial gt450 scanner we routinely use
the like a versa scanner for both
chromogenic and bright field but I
really appreciate the the speed of
scanning using the Imperial gt450 it's
very rapid it takes in seconds to
minutes so it's very applicable to high
throughput staining and imaging
so what are the advantages of
multiplexing
well over there on the left we're
showing standard IHC staining there are
three sections each stained with a
different biomarker on the right we show
ultraplex staining where one section is
stained simultaneously with three
biomarkers
so for both of these staining
Technologies it's simple rapid and uses
standard laboratory equipment
but the one over there on the left uses
three slides and one biomarker a slide
so this does waste precious tissue
as I mentioned earlier increasingly
tissue samples are smaller for example
the needle core biopsies where often you
might get three or five sections per
core
and these have to be applied to
different detection Technologies maybe
you might be looking at RNA expression
as well so to use three sections for one
staining is wasteful
so this is sold using the ultraflex
technology also you only see a single
biomarker per slide and many of the
different subpopulations of cells we
look at now are only identified by
multiple biologs per slides so you you
aren't able to detect those
over there on the right you can see
three biomarkers shown on one tissue
section so again this is tissue
conserving it frees up those other
sections for different readouts it also
gives you multi-parametric analysis so
you can look at co-expression of two
biomarkers on the same cell population
and it also gives you information on
context so for example the tumor cells
are shown there in yellow
CD4 cells are shown in blue and cd8
cells in Red so you can see where the
immune cells are relative to the tumor
and also relative to each other
so this is showing our ultraplex human
chromogenic Multiplex IHC ready to use
panels the first panel cpo1 targets cd8
pdl1 and pansy K using red blue and
yellow chromogens
cpo2 targets cd8 CD4 and pan CK again
using red blue and yellow chromogens the
cpo3 stains for cd68 and cd163
and also for pdl1 so this is basically
looking at pdo1 expression on different
subsets of macrophages
the chromogens we use are the red Bond
polymer fine red detection kit for blue
the Leica blue chromogen and for yellow
the cell palette yellow chromogen which
is included in the CPU one through cpo3
kits
so this next slide shows are cpo1
through cpo2 cpo3 staining profiles if
you look over there to the left cpo1 you
can see staining of tonsil using cd8
those are the small red cells over there
to the right
hansika expression alone is shown in
yellow and pdl1 expression alone is
shown in blue and you can see clump of
cells there over about 11 o'clock and
some also blue cells alone in the center
of the section
where pdl1 and pan CK are co-expressed
the yellow and the blue chromogens
produce a green color so by carefully
selecting our biomarkers and our
chromogens we can actually look at
co-expression of biomarkers micromogenic
staining now we're used to seeing this
on fluorescence but it's unusual to be
able to see it on chromogenic staining
by by the choice of these chromogens
we're able to detect it using ultraplex
the metal panel cpo2 is looking at CD4
and cd8 cell infiltration into two
molests so this is colorectal cancer you
can see it with a yellow staining and
you can quite clearly see infiltration
of use CD4 cells and red cd8 cells into
the tumor Nest that
all over to the right is cpo3 so the
cd68 cells are shown in red the cd163
cells are shown in yellow and whatever's
co-expression may appear as Orange
you can see a lot of cells which are
pdl1 expressing alone those would be the
tumor cells and you can also see some
blue pdo1 expression on the kind of
oranging macrophage cells but it's much
harder to see when you're looking at
three biomarker expression micromogenic
we're really looking at Double by Mark
expression would be The Sweet Spot
on this slide I just wanted to Showcase
how we can easily adapt
um here's an example this is cp01 so
instead of staining for pancake and
yellow we're staining with cd68
you look at the foremost panel on the
right this is lung adenocarcinoma at the
highest magnification
small red cells are cd8 cells which are
mainly there in the stroma
the blue cells alone will be the tumor
cells staying with pdl1 and then the
cd68 cells you can see is yellow cells
now quite a few of those also have
expression of CDH shown in red and this
alarm may I have judgment when I first
saw it but when we showed it to our
Pathologists he said that that was quite
normal in the the lung biopsies that you
might see cd8 on your cd68 acrophages
and if you look about 12 o'clock you can
see a couple of cells there which also
show membrane staining with pdl1 so in
this section you see both tumor cells
and macrophages expressed in pdl1
in this next slide uh it's the same
panel but we've replaced cd68 with cd163
again on the far right you can see the
cd8 killer T cells
the CD 163 and two macrophages are shown
as the yellow
macrophages with some of them have red
on them but I will be honest in this
particular section I can't see any
co-expression with pdl1 but it doesn't
mean to say that that wasn't any in this
section just not in this particular View
and again I wanted to show you the cd8
pto1 pdl1 and pan CK panel the this is a
very nice illustration of the
co-expression here the cd8 cells in red
are shown can mainly in the stroma the
yellow cells are the tumor cells and
then the
areas where pdl1 is coexpressed on the
tumor has shown as that very strong
green color which is really interesting
that it is very concentrated on the
interface with the stroma the outward
facing interface whereas the center of
the tumor has very little PD elements so
I'm always fascinated by these images
here on this section we're showing very
different patient profiles this was a
non-small cell lung cancer TMA so three
different patient samples using the CPU
one panel the panel over there on the
far left
shows pretty much all of the tumor cells
also co-express pdl1 there are some red
cells there in the cdxls in the two in
the stroma but I don't see any of them
infiltrating into the tumor in the
middle panel you see a lot of cd8 killer
cells in the stroma a few of them are
infiltrating into the tumor but the
tumor is very noticeable in that it
expresses no pdl1
over there on the right you can see
quite a few cd8 cells infiltrating the
tumor but the tumor is buried in its
level of pdl1 expression you can see
some cells which express it but not but
also some tumor cells which don't so
again three very different profiles
all from the same tumor type but
different patients
on this slide on the left I'm just
showing you a higher power view of the
slide I showed you earlier so that you
can very clearly see the membrane
staining for her too in blue
the red nuclear staining for the
estrogen receptor and the orange nucleus
staining where you get nuclear
co-expression of estrogen receptor and
progesterone receptor over there on the
right is showing staining of tonsil and
it's just showcasing a four-plex
chromogenic panel
in the center of the slide you can see
red staining for cd8 killer cells over
there on the left you have pancake
staining a bone
and the green area about seven o'clock
is where you get co-expression of pansy
K and pdl1 which is green so if you look
there over to the right that would be a
germinal center showing rapidly staining
cells which are detected using an anti
ki-67 antibody and the Leica green
chromogen so these two greens are quite
different and I have to say I really
like the Leica green chromogen it shows
very very nice staining
this is just another four-plex panel in
this case what we've added in to cpo2 is
staining of macrophages with a black
chromogen over the standing tonsil on
the left and Lung and no carcinoma on
the right
so on this slide we show the
reproducibility of the chromogenic
staining on the lung cancer biopsies so
we took 10 slides and we stained them
with the cpo1 panel
then these slides we're using the purple
hematoxin and I wanted to mention that
because all the previous slides had used
the pale blue hematoxylinders so that
you could see the difference between
them if you look at the sections
themselves and also the bar graphs to
the right
you can see that there is
very strong reproducibility slight Slide
the error bars are very small staining
both the pansy K and for the pansy K
pdl1co expression you can see most of
the pancake expressing tumor cells also
Express pdl1 both from the bar graphs
and also if you look at the slides the
um the co-expression is shown as that
dark green brown staining
also the cd8 T cells in red again very
reproducible slight slide
in this slide we're showing image
analysis of breast cancer stained with
her2er and PR
we use multiple different image analysis
programs and we have image analysis
agnostic but in this particular analysis
we were using Visio Farm
the image over there to the left is the
app of the breast cancer sample
the image in the middle is where we
applied the mask which is the
thresholding and then the image over
there to the right is with the mask
added where we are showing for example
her2 staining alone the cells are shown
in green and on this particular slide we
had about 75 000 cells staining her2
alone
the estrogen receptor staining alone is
shown in blue and there are about 34 000
cells and then the estrogen receptor
progesterone receptor co-expression is
shown in red and there are about 33 000
cells in this particular slide
this is image analysis of lung cancer
again using physio bomb analysis on the
panel staining it is the CPO one cd8
pencil K and pdl1 panel the two images
over there to the left
where we analyze specifically the stroma
areas
and the top with the mask off and the
bottom with the mask on so the red cells
are the cd8 staining cells alone and the
blue cells and cells which express pdl1
alone the two panels there over to the
right we analyze specifically the tumor
cells the pdl1 pound CK positive cells
are shown there in the bottom right
panel as blue cells and then the pansy
key tumor cells which express fancy K
alone are shown in Brown
and there we've analyzed and you can see
in the Biograph we've analyzed about 350
000 cells and it shows the percentage of
those different subpopulations
so the ultraplex kits are available for
staining 10 slides and they also include
an additional aliquate of secondary
antibodies alone so you can add a
negative control which is staying with
the secondary alone it requires the use
of the bond direct staining system
buffers reagents and detection kits of
course we have larger kits available on
request
so in summary ultraplex chromogenic
Multiplex IHC is a rapid plug-and-play
technology for tissue profiling it
allows automated detection
three markers and a notice stainer and
four and a half hours using primary
antibodies from any species while
employing a single and true retrieval
step
panels I've shown you and all the ones
that we offer are ffp tissue optimized
for key biomarkers this allows rapid
scanning
and avoids autofluorescence issues so
I'm a big fan of ultraplex fluorescent
staining but there are
some tissues for example like prostate
or lung cancer which sometimes have
order fluorescence using the fluorescent
readout which obviously you avoid using
the chromogenic readout and variable to
very rapidly scan your slides and we
also have custom panels available
we get chromogenic detection of cell
subtypes coexpressing biomarkers using
our optimized approaching combinations
so let's change it up a little bit here
and talk about fluorescent staining
so using ultraplex fluorescent Multiplex
IHC and this is a simple flexible fast
and fully automated technology it
generates beautiful images and data on
biologic expression and spatial
localization
key cell subtypes using the bond direct
staining system and the Imperial versus
scanner
the flow diagram again is the one that
I've shown you previously but here I
just want to emphasize in the panel
below
the options that you have for
fluorescent staining so we have ready to
use panels
fluorescent human Multiplex
we have modular select your own panels
for both human and mouse and we have
custom panels available again for human
and lamps
you can run these panels using the bond
direct staining system but 7.0 staining
software
the the fluorescent staining protocol
will be added to the next protocol
upgrade which happened very soon but in
the meantime all of the cell idx
suggested Protocols are available on the
cell idx website so you can download
more
the image over there is produced using
the Imperial versus scanner and it
showcases very nicely the staining of
the tumor in red the orange area is a
co-expression of pencil K with pdo1 so
that's two cells expressing pdo1 the
green infiltrating cells are cd8 and
then the I think you can see some
macrophages which are outside the tumor
those are the purple expressing cells
here I'm showing you a higher power of
the the fluorescent multiplexer breast
cancer panel that I showed you earlier
and again you can see the red membrane
is staining for her too the blue and
green nuclear staining for estrogen
receptor and the progesterone receptor
respectively and the turquoise staining
where they co-express and then the
staining for KO 67 in the nucleus is the
pink stain so again it's a simple
two-step staining procedure which is
very rapid it's easy to implement it has
a single anti-retrieval which is rapid
and tissue conserving it's antibody
species independent it uses cocktails of
antibody which allows simultaneous
detection and the panels are all ffpe
tissue optimized
so routinely we produce four Plex panels
because those are they can easily be
detect on most main scanners and so you
could be detected on the liver versus
scanner but we can also produce five
Flex panels but what we often do with
our four Plex panels is serial section
overlay so for example over there the
upper left you can see the breast cancer
panel I showed you earlier and at the
bottom right you can see a basic immune
panel and even without overlaying those
two panels you can see in this patient
they have a quite a strong immune
response but the problem is that it's
not gaining access into the tumor
yeah
and I wanted to just pause there and
also emphasize a little bit about the
speed of the the rapidity of these
sections we talked about a few minutes
ago about how rapid it is to do staining
but I also wanted to emphasize here how
rapid it is to rearrange those panels so
for us if we want to rearrange a four
Flex panel seed to add in
an additional one or two biomarkers all
we need to do is remove those antibodies
from the cocktail and add in one of what
is into the cocktail and we can create
those very rapidly so it helps you to
really rapidly evolve your research you
might stain one section
um and then
scan it and analyze it in one day you
can look at the data it might
give you an idea of a different stain
that you want it to do you could order
another modular panel it will arrive
very rapidly you can even stain the
cereal section and then overlay them as
I've shown here
to really uh
enable you to ask questions and address
them and evolve your research very very
rapidly so that is one of the other
advantages of ultraplex
over here I'm sharing a very basic
T-cell phenotyping panel using CD4 cd8
Fox P3 and t-bet if you look at the four
small images going from left to right
you have membrane standing for CD4 and
nuclear staining a fox P3 so that's a
t-reg next to it you have membrane
stating of CD4 and nuclear Tibet which
is a th1
next to that would be a membrane
staining for CDA nucleotiba which would
be a tc1 and then right next to that we
have membrane stating for CD4 and the
nuclear expression of those for both Fox
P3 and t-bit and you can see just a
couple of those cells in the
larger image so that's a very rare
subpopulation which may be a suppressor
cell for th1 cells but in this
particular patient's melanoma patients
tissue sample you see quite a lot of the
tcm1 cells
just wanted to insert this slide here
because we have expanded R versus
scanner to actually detect
four different biomarkers for stapy
using a mega Stokes eye and a custom
filter Cube from chroma
so if you look at the table of floors
the cl490 550 650 and 750 are the floor
force that we usually use with our
pre-made panels and those are regular
floors using their usual
um 25 nanometer Stoke shift if you look
at the lowest line the fifth one down
that's a mega stead style so that has a
much greater Stoke shift it's about 130
nanometers so by using this die with the
extra filter cue we can actually
detect five different biologies as long
as the expression is strong you're able
to do this so it gives you an additional
flexibility
so here are our ready to use panels so
they're four Plex panels and if you work
in the air and immuno oncology they'll
make perfect sense to you
we had a
demand for these but a lot of people
will be asking say for example uh they
wanted to
biomarker for another biomarker and we
have a lot of different qualified
antibodies and we're always developing
new targets
so what we did was we released what's
called ultraplex modular so this is
really selecting your own Multiplex
panel you look at the menu of qualified
file markers and you get to choose the
four that you want to include into your
panel you choose your floor for
combination and then you select kits by
the 10 or 50 slides and we can also
obviously make custom panels on demand
and this again is just showing the cd4c8
fox P3 t-bet panel
now I want it to change to show you
ultraplex Mouse modular panels so again
this is the same approach that we have
for the human all the antibodies are ffp
tissue optimized you get to choose the
four biomarkers you want for my
qualified panel again choose the thought
combination and select kits for 10 or 50
slides and again here we can also make
custom panels on demand
this is just showcasing different
modular panels that we've created just
to give you an idea of what we can
produce
if you look over there on the left panel
for the ffpe spleen
this is a CD3 CD4 cd8 Fox P3 staining
panel Fox P3 is in yellow so you can see
a lot of nice yellow nuclear stain put a
lot of T-Rex in there staining of the
spleen if you look there on the right
you could see staining of the a mouse
lung cancer model Keras tumor
there are very few red nuclear staining
cells so yellow nuclear staining cells
there's a very few Fox P3 and this
particular section
we show Green cd8 cells so there's quite
a few cd8 cells there and quite a lot of
purple CD4 cells in this particular area
of the section
this panel stains for cd8 plus P3 f480
is a macrophage marker and cd11b
if you look at the KRS tumor stain there
on the right there are a lot of f480
macro Pages there and very very few
all right
Fox P3 yellow cells and just a few
cd8 T cells
so this is an interesting panel over
there on the right you can see a lot of
B cells staining in green
staying with b220
you can see a few red macrophages
and you can see cd11 B cells in purple
that would sustain a variety of
different cells but we've also stained
for myeloprostas and yellows so where
you get double expression of myeloprops
stays in cd11b which would be
neutrophils you can see these very
bright purple and white cells
again over here on the right these are
staining with a bond RX and scanning
with the Opera versus scanner
this slide shows staining of different
Mouse and genetic tumor models so the
left is a breast cancer model and what's
really striking with this staining is
that so the panel is cd8 cd163 Fox P3
and k67 there are a very large number of
proliferating cd8 cells in this
particular view of this breast cancer
model so those have membrane staining
yellow for cd8 and nuclear standing in
purple for ka67 and then a few green
empty macrophages
pancreatic tumor there on the right
there's a lot of proliferating cells but
it looks like those are mainly tumor
cells you have a few
green CD 163 cells and then quite a few
yellow cd8 cells and a few Fox P3 T-Rex
over there on the left you have the CD
ct26 colon tumor model
again a lot of green cd163 macrophages
and a few yellow and purple property
proliferating T cells so you can see a
little Nest over there about four
o'clock
the tumor to the right is the hyper
tumor hepatic tumor model you can see a
few c163 cells and a few cd8 T cells in
yellow and which don't appear to be
proliferating
now and none of these are we saying
these whether these are hot or cold two
models but these are just areas where we
focus where we saw staining
and here I just wanted to show you an
example of mouse chromogenic Multiplex
IHC so these panels on request this is
showing normal Mouse colon stained with
pencil K in yellow
and then close to that you can see the
cd163 macrophages stained in red and
lower down in the image you can see a
lot of blue CDA T cells
and finally I wanted to talk to you a
little about the ultra Tech Multiplex
labeling kits which allow you to develop
your own Multiplex IHC pounds
so this is a very simple labeling
procedure for 50 micrograms of antibody
your antibody needs to be a high
Affinity antibody and the antibody needs
to be about
a needs to be around a Miguel
concentration without additional BSA
so the tagging is obviously a pretty
species independent it's very efficient
tagging and it takes about 20 minutes
Hands-On time which will be about two
hours start to finish
so we have Ultra tag kits available to
make up to four Plex fluorescent panels
and three Plex chromogenic panels so if
you look at the list of kits you need
one kit to label each image body so if
you wanted to make a full Plex
which you could use on the say for
example firstly you would probably
choose the ultra tag for 90 550 650 and
750 kits if you could do spectral and
mixing you might choose the 490 550
595 and 650 kits if you wanted to do
chromogenic make a chromogenic panel you
would choose the AP the hlp1 and the
hrp2 kits
so these are inclusive kits which
contain the tag labeling the agent to
label one antibody and then they also
include either the fluorescent labeled
or the enzyme label detector antibody
and I think that we've come to the end
of the the talk but I will be delighted
to take questions if anybody has them
thank you Helen for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
all right so let's get started we have
some great questions coming in from our
audience we'll start with this one
Helen what are the differences between
the set panels modular panels and custom
panels
uh thank you Kelly so the set panels are
the human fluorescent panels and the
human chromogenic panels so those would
be the CPO one sorry the hi1 through ha6
which the fluorescent panels and they
would they make a lot of sense that say
for example hiv4 stain and cd8
cd68 pansy K and pdl1 so that will be
looking if you're working in immuno
oncology you'll be looking at
infiltrating cd8 cells and pdl1
expression on either tumor cells or on
macrophages
of a CPO one uh through three of the
chromogenic panels so those will be all
of the
pre-made panels
so if you if the panel that you're
interested in is there that's great if
they if it isn't then you can look at
our modular panels so those would be
both human and mouse fluorescent
multiplexing so there you basically look
at the menu of qualified biomarkers you
choose the four that you're interested
in and the fluorophore sets and just
place your order
and the ready to use panels obviously
they're off the shelf they're you know
shipped immediately the modular are
available very very rapidly and they you
know be a couple of days if we have to
rearrange things it might take a little
bit longer but it's very very rapid now
if you can't find the panels that you
want either with the pre-made panels or
with modular then you can order custom
kits so any of the chromogenic panels
which we don't have available pre-made
you could order those as a custom panel
or if you have
antibodies that you particularly want to
use maybe they're against biomarkers
that we don't already have we can make
those in chromogenic or fluorescent form
first customer panels so those are the
those are the three options the custom
obviously will take a little bit longer
but we're also very efficient of that
too
great thank you another question I have
for you here what floor sets are
available for the human and mouse
fluorescent panels
so the human fluorescent panels use are
a panel floors so that would be CL 490
550 650 and 750 so those are the ones
that we routinely use on our Leica versa
if you have a scanner that can
spectrally unmix you might want to have
the panel floors which are 490 by 50 595
and 650.
we also have other floors available so
for example
cl532 is very popular particularly if
people are interested in using the
nanostring geomix platform technology
often they will order a panel using
490 532 and 650. so there's a lot of
there's a lot of flexibility there with
with the modular panels
now Helen can this ultraplex technology
be used with xenograph models
thank you that's a that's a good
question we have not done the staining
in-house but Theory it should be perfect
for looking at xenograph models so
sometimes
people want to use Mouse monoclonals to
detect the human tissue grafted into the
mouse mouse host and then using an
anti-mouse
species specific detection reagent where
sometimes they might see
cross-reactivity on the Mouse tissue
so I think as I said before we because
we tag our antibodies we're not
detecting them by the species we're
detecting them by the attack so it
should in theory be a perfect solution
and avoid any Mouse on Mouse problems
you might have using Mouse water funnels
and the humans underground patient
derived cenographina models
great
another question I have for you here you
showed staining using red blue and
yellow chromogens can you use others
Yes actually I also showed the images
using the the black chromogen and then
also the glyco green chromogen so I like
the like a green very much we actually
have a red blue green protocol on the
the bond RX I don't think it's available
for
um
most Jews but it is programmed in this
so if you call like they might enable
you to use the red blue green
chromogen protocol too
um if you wanted to use for the
chromogens I would just suggest that you
give cell idx a call we've really
optimized it with the red blue yellow
um in terms of the the order and the
biomarker chromogen combinations but if
you wanted to try something else just
just give us a call and we can chat
about and how feasible that might be
perfect
next question here asks you said you
supply both blue and purple counter
stains with the kit why would you choose
one versus the other
well there are two really two answers to
that question the first would be
cosmetic you might just prefer one to
the other I showed you in the serial
section staining with the light purple
counter stain and actually I think you
can still see the image of the
the pale blue Cam stain on the screen so
you might just you might just prefer one
to the other
second probably more important answer is
in terms of analysis so depending on
which analysis program you're using
you might find that it works better
using the pale blue or the pale purple
hematoxin so we include both so that you
can try it ahead of time and choose the
one which gives you the the best
definition and the best analysis
great we have time for a few more
questions here we'll proceed with this
next one do any of your panels work on
non-human primates or other species
that's a really good question too I uh I
did look quite a while ago to see if it
was cross-reactivity and I did not find
very much data on but not to say that
they don't just that there's a lot of
data at the time
but we're very transparent about what
clones found toys we use so they're on
the website so you can easily see what
we're using for the staining but I think
that the best solution for that whether
you're staining non-human primates or
maybe even tissue dog tissue samples or
cats would be the ultratech kits so as
long as you've got
a good high Affinity antibody about Nick
pamel with no BSA the ultra tag kids
should work very well and when I say a
good high Affinity antibody what I'm
really talking about is an antibody that
titrates down well so when we qualify
antibodies one of our first steps is
that we
we do a titration from one microgram per
ml to 0.2 to 0.04 micrograms per ml so a
good antibody will stain well up below
microgram well so if you have that kind
of antibody
it would be a good candidate for tagging
the ultra Tech and then you could tab
all your own antibodies and regardless
of the host tissue you can if you have
the antibody you can create multiple an
ultraplex panel either fluorescent or
chronogenic
great thank you
next question where can I find the
protocols to run the bond RX
well if you have the version 7.0
software
um the chromogenic will be
pre-programmed in there and I believe if
you have 6.0 you can always upgrade it
to 7.0
for the fluorescence they are going to
be on the pre-programmed protocol very
soon but in the meantime if you go to
the cell idx website and I think it's
the support menu at the Top If You pull
that down to the protocols tab then you
can download any of our protocols and
that would include the fluorescent
staining protocol that we recommend for
using on the bond RX
great but looks like we have time for
one more question so we'll wrap up after
this one can I use any imager or scanner
for my stained slides
both with the chromogenic slides it's
just using a bright field microscopy so
you can use any prior fuel microscope or
scanner for the fluorescent stain slides
just make sure that you use the
the panel the floor full panel that
works with your scanner like I said
before a lot of people have scanners
which could detect the a panel floors so
that's 490 550 650 and 750 other people
can do Spectrum mixing so they would
want the the panel floor so just make
sure that you you choose the panel that
you can actually see when you when you
scan afterwards
great well thank you again Helen for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Leica biosystems
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
leverage will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye